the master chief collection will be
optimized for the series x and
s you can stream games from your xbox
one to your iphone
and also cyberpunk will have full lip
sync for all its supported languages
i'm chasity here with the biggest news
of the day let's jump in
[Music]
halo the master chief collection will
get some enhancements on series x
and s every game in the collection will
get support for 120 fps and up to 4k
and local split screen will get some
additional optimization on series x
specifically the collection will be
updated on november 17th
one week after the console's launch the
update will be free thanks to xbox's
smart delivery program
the collection is also included in xbox
game pass on console and pc
series xns launched on november 10th so
tune in to gamespot's weekly show
generation next for all the latest as
launch gets closer
speaking of xbox games the xbox app on
ios just got an update that lets you
stream games from your xbox one to your
iphone or
ipad you can do this locally or remotely
over lte and 5g connections
this is similar to playstation's remote
play but instead of needing an
additional app it's right there in the
xbox app
you can stream games from your xbox one
and you'll be able to do the same for
the series x and s when they launch but
it doesn't work with backwards
compatible 360 and original xbox games
this is distinct from microsoft's xcloud
service which lets you stream games from
the cloud
the app only pulls games you have on
your physical console cyberpunk 2077 is
out soon and no matter which of its 10
languages you use to play the game
the character's mouths will be synced
correctly animating for a single
language is already a lot of work
so developer cd projekt red teamed up
with jolly research inc to speed up the
process with a model that automates the
animation process
incorrect lip syncing can ruin your
immersion for example ghost of
tsushima's characters always move their
mouths as if speaking english
even if you play in japanese which some
consider the best way to play
we'll have to see how well these 10
different language animations hold up
when the game comes out the game
launches for ps4 xbox one and pc on
november 19th
and next gen versions with free upgrades
are also in the works
and that's your save save for tuesday
i'm chasity and you can follow me on
twitter at chastity underscore
v come back tomorrow for more news and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you